the story kicks off back in the good old
days when humans had electricity in
Chicago a young Charlie is watching
Looney Tunes little Danny is playing
with an iPad and their mother Rachel
Chats on the phone suddenly the father
Ben bursts inside and with a worried
look he informs them that they don't
have much time left Rachel seems to know
what he's talking about elsewhere two
guys are seen going somewhere via the
main Highway one of them is Ben's
brother miles and the other one is his
friend miles receives a call from Ben
who frantically tells him it's all going
to turn off and it will never ever turn
back on confused miles asks his brother
to explain calmly but just then his
phone gets switched off at the same time
his friend's smartphone also blanks out
automatically on the other hand as
lights begin to flicker Ben checks his
laptop which says downloading files just
in time it hits 100 after which he pulls
a USB plug from the laptop and slips it
into a metallic triangular locket-like
thing on the highway miles and his
friends step off of their stalled car to
witness a stream of headlights
flickering off one car at a time planes
start crashing here and there
Transformers explode and Catch Fire And
even the iconic Willis Tower goes pitch
black we are then shown an aerial view
of the globe which shows that lights are
going out everywhere it starts in the
northeast corner of the US and spreads
West and Southward the world is falling
into chaos guess it's time to bust out
the old playing cards and books by
candlelight a fate which gen Z views as
worse than death then we hear a
narration which informs us that 15 years
have passed since that fateful day After
the Blackout nothing worked all
electronic items were rendered useless
and not only that car engines jet
turbines and even small batteries became
defunct this created a chain of events
that caused Mass casualties sickness
without medicine fires Without fire
truck food without factories soon
governments fell and malicious started
Rising After the Blackout the United
States was divided into six parts the
Monroe Republic the Georgia Federation
the plains Nation Texas the California
Commonwealth's and the Wasteland due to
the terrorizing state of the Cities most
people have left for other safer places
Ben and his family are among those as
they have relocated to the countryside
it is a peaceful colony in the Monroe
Republic where a few hundred people have
settled it is revealed that Ben's wife
Rachel passed away a few years ago and
now he is dating a British medical
doctor named Maggie the children Danny
and Charlie are also grown up now but
Dany is vulnerable to being alone as he
has severe asthma one day as Charlie is
out in the forest with her brother she
finds an abandoned RV curious she gets
inside and finds a mini fridge that
reminds her of something minutes After
the Blackout her parents let her eat all
the ice cream that was melting because
that would be the last ice cream she
ever had a few days later as Charlie is
out on one of her usual Expeditions in
the forest the main military force of
the Monroe Republic the Monroe militia
barges into the colony the militia have
the Monroe Republic simple branded on
their wrist to identify them as simps
for Maryland I mean as members as this
settlement is located in the Monroe
Republic the residents have an
obligation to to give up their crops as
a form of tax however Ben knows that
this is more than just a tax issue
realizing that something bad is about to
happen he approaches his good friend
Aaron and hands him the locket which
contains the USB that we saw earlier he
tells him to keep the locket safe no
matter what then the captain of the
militia group Major Tom Neville asks for
Ben to come with them he also inquires
about his brother miles but Ben replies
that they haven't met in 15 years as
everyone watches in fear the militia
prepares to leave but just then Danny
points a crossbow at them threatening
them to let his father go Ben tries to
calm the situation down but to no avail
unfortunately he is the first one to be
shot and because of this Dany takes down
an enemy soon the villagers also start
attacking the militia but they are of no
match after several people are killed
Tom and his army finally leave but not
before taking Dany with them as a
hostage a while later Charlie finally
arrives and finds her father lying in a
pool of blood with his last breaths he
informs her that Dany has been kidnapped
by the militia and now their only hope
to retrieve him is Miles who is living
in Chicago Charlie pleads with him to
hang on but Ben tells her to find Uncle
miles before passing away expectedly
Charlie is devastated by the incident
but she has no time to grieve she packs
her belongings and gets ready to head
out alone but a concerned Maggie and
Aaron also decide to join her much to
Charlie's dismay the trio travels the
entire day through dangerous terrain and
forms a close bond with each other the
next morning when Charlie heads to a
nearby waterfall to fetch some water she
comes across a dangerous looking man
named Nate since the world is plunged
into total Anarchy After the Blackout
every new individual is deemed to be a
threat even more so for a girl like
Charlie no I'm saying but luckily for
her Nate simply asks her name and then
lets her go that evening Charlie and her
group find an abandoned plane and decide
to sleep inside but unfortunately it
turns out to be The Hideout of a group
of scavengers the thugs hold the three
at knife point and one of them takes
Charlie away realizing the danger Maggie
cleverly makes the other thugs drink
some whiskey which she had poisoned her
earlier and as soon as they do they
choke to death on the other hand the
final Thug tries to have his way with
Charlie but just then Nate arrives in
the nick of time and saves her the next
morning he accompanies the group as it
turns out that he is also heading to
Chicago Maggie is skeptical about the
new member in the squad and warns
Charlie that they shouldn't trust anyone
but the latter reminds her that not
everyone is bad elsewhere as Major Tom
and his army are resting Danny manages
to free himself from his shackles and
fleas he runs the whole night and gets
far away from the militia but eventually
collapses near a house due to an asthma
attack a few hours later he wakes up
inside the house and finds a lady
pointing her rifle at him she introduces
herself as Grace and inquires how he
ended up here Dany responds that he was
kidnapped and hearing this the woman
finally lowers her guard she also hands
him an inhaler mentioning that it
belonged to her late son elsewhere the
group finally reaches the city of
Chicago which is also located in Monroe
Republic It's a sight to behold Wrigley
Field is covered in ivy plants streets
are filled with fish vendors and the
Volkswagen Beetle cars turned into horse
buggies following the information given
by Ben they reach a hotel and ask the
bartender about a certain miles Matheson
at first the bartender denies knowing
anyone by that name but when Charlie
mentions that her father has recently
died he speaks up he reveals that he
himself is miles but he has been keeping
his identity a secret due to security
reasons he's literally the first person
they talked to so he's not doing a great
job of hiding shortly after miles takes
his niece inside and talks to her
privately Charlie tells him everything
about how the militia killed her father
and kidnapped Danny she then inquires
about why they are after her family to
which miles responds that Ben knew
something about the blackout the leader
of the Monroe Republic General Monroe is
a cruel dictator who wants to take
control over the entire country and
eventually the world but for that he
needed weapons like tanks fighter planes
and even nuclear bombs and since Ben was
the only guy who knew about the
Blackout's cause Monroe believed that he
could reverse it hearing all this
Charlie becomes Eva even more concerned
about her brother and asks her uncle to
help her but surprisingly he refuses he
claims that the mission is too risky and
it's not worth fighting for distraught
Charlie heads back to her group and
prepares to leave seeing her upset an
overprotective Nate confronts miles and
almost gets into a fight but instead
gets his identity exposed from his wrist
it turns out that Nate is also a member
of the Monroe militia and he was
following Charlie in the group just so
he could get to Miles everyone is
stunned by the Revelation but before
they can take action Nate runs away
despite his location being compromised
miles still refuses to leave his Hideout
he asserts that he will face the militia
alone if he has to Charlie and the group
offer to help him but miles shouts at
them forcing them to leave in no time a
large army of militia including Nate
arrives and starts fighting with miles
but despite being outnumbered he uses
his incredible sword skills and Agility
to kill the enemies one by one soon
Charlie and the Gang also return and
join the fight making it slightly more
even amidst the chaos a member of the
militia tries to kill Charlie but
surprisingly Nate knocks him out before
running away after a while miles kills
the captain of the militia group and
eventually ends the fight he then agrees
to join Charlie and the others to find
Dany making everyone excited following
this miles has a flashback about the
night of the blackout after the whole
world goes dark he gets out of his car
along with his friend they then return
to their Marine Corps Base revealing
that the two of them are Marines there a
flash of the friend's tattoo an m in the
same style as the malicious symbol
reveals that miles's friend is none
other than Sebastian Monroe the current
leader of the Monroe Republic elsewhere
Major Tom and his men follow Danny's
Footprints and arrive outside Grace's
house initially the kind woman tries to
save the boy but when Major Tom
threatens to kill her she steps aside
with this the militia barges inside the
house and recaptures Dany after they are
gone Grace covertly goes to the basement
and takes out her pendant which is
similar to the one that Aaron is
carrying when she presses it
surprisingly a light bulb inside the
room starts glowing Grace then plugs the
pendant into her makeshift computer and
starts chatting with someone the guy on
the other side is relieved that the
militia didn't catch her secret
elsewhere miles leads the group to a
Tavern he is looking for a former
associate named Nora who supposedly is a
master in creating explosives miles
tells Charlie that if they are to rescue
Dany they will need a skilled fighter
like Nora at the tavern he is suddenly
attacked by a few bounty hunters but
once again he comes out on top he then
chokes one of the men and forces him to
reveal Nora's location it turns out that
she has been apprehended by the militia
and is currently working as a slave at
night miles decides to go on the journey
alone claiming that it is too dangerous
he then tells the rest of the group to
meet in exactly two weeks in Lowell
Indiana however the next morning when
Maggie and Aaron wake up they find out
that the stubborn Charlie has also
laughed much to their annoyance left
with no other options Aaron finally
shows Maggie the pendant that Ben gave
him he also reveals that Ben instructed
him to meet a woman called Grace in
Grant Park Illinois although the two are
still worried about Charlie they assume
that she she will be fine and instead
head to Grant Park to find Grace along
the way the two talk about how Grace
could be the key in restoring energy
back to the Earth and they get excited
on the other hand as Major Tom is
leading his army back to their base a
gunshot is heard hence he changes course
and follows the sound until he reaches a
small house it turns out that in this
Monroe Republic civilians can't own guns
and ammunition this is the reason why
everybody uses crossbows and other
short-range weapons to make a statement
Major Tom threatens the owner of the
house to give up all of his weapons
realizing that he will be killed anyway
the man shoots one of Tom's men before
getting shot himself as all of this
transpires a terrified Dany looks on at
the malicious base we are formally
introduced to General Monroe he is the
main evil behind all this cruelty and is
a longing for world domination Monroe
interrogates a civilian about the
shortage of weapons but when the scared
man doesn't answer he brutally finishes
him off later he enters a room and
approaches one of his workers she is
revealed to be Ben's wife Rachel who is
assumed by everyone to be dead Monroe
breaks the news that Ben has passed away
and hearing this Rachel gets visibly
upset meanwhile Charlie travels the
whole day in the forest and eventually
finds her uncle as expected miles is
angry at her for disobeying his orders
but when Charlie mentions that her
brother is prone to asthma attacks he
calms down soon the two come across a
large number of slaves who are
apparently transporting a helicopter it
turns out that General Monroe is so sure
that the energy will return someday that
he has already started preparing himself
for world domination among the slaves is
also Nora but saving her will be
difficult as there are several guards
one of whom is carrying a sniper rifle
despite the risks miles is adamant on
saving his friend he waits until the
night and sets his plan in motion at
first he creates a distraction and lures
away the guards then he sneaks near the
slaves and eventually frees Nora but to
his dismay he learns that Nora had
voluntarily become a slave as she wanted
to steal the sniper rifle snipers are an
extremely rare weapon in this world
after a bit of catching up miles tells
Nora that he needs her help in rescuing
his nephew she immediately agrees but in
return asks his help to retrieve the
sniper rifle miles is reluctant but he
has no choice but to agree after a while
the three head to a nearby Hut and start
planning using gunpowder Nora makes a
makeshift weapon which will be used to
kill the guard with the sniper however
the problem is that the weapon will be
effective only from a few meters this
means that someone will have to approach
the guard and shoot him miles and Nora
will easily be detected and that leaves
Charlie as the only viable option before
leaving miles assures her that they will
take out the rest of the guards as soon
as she makes the kill shortly after
Charlie hides the weapon inside her
sleeves pretends to be a lost traveler
and approaches the guards she then gets
near the guard with the sniper and takes
him out immediately and before the other
guards can do anything miles and Nora
Ambush them and finish them off after
the altercation as the slaves are being
freed Nora reveals that she stole the
sniper for the rebels a bunch of
patriotic folks who want to liberate the
country from the militia at Grant Park
as Grace is typing on her computer
someone barges inside her house and
confronts her he also has a locket like
hers which is releasing energy into his
taser stick on the other hand miles
tries his best to convince Nora to leave
the rebel gang but she refuses here it
is revealed that the two were a couple
once but had to break up After the
Blackout I guess not being able to
scroll their socials during dates made
them realize they didn't like each other
shortly after they arrive at a rebel
base which is ironically led by a holy
Pastor the pastor is happy that Nora
brought the sniper but shares the bad
news that their army has just been
ambushed when the group gets inside the
base they find several men either dead
or severely injured the pastor also
reveals that one of the men is missing
and hearing this miles tells everyone to
leave the place immediately he believes
that the militia is interrogating their
man and it is only a matter of time
before their location is compromised
Nora agrees but asks for 30 minutes as
they have to patch up the wounded man
unfortunately their decision turns out
to be fatal as after just a few minutes
the militia led by Captain Adam shows up
to buy them some some time miles orders
their best shooter to head upstairs with
the sniper the plan works as the guy
starts taking down several of the
malicious men forcing them to retreat
the standoff lasts so long that it has
now become night inside the base miles
and the group are trying to make a
tunnel through the wall so that they can
get to the other side however their plan
fails miserably when the wall becomes
loose and falls into the hole they just
dug hence destroying their hard work at
the same time the sniper on the roof
also gets killed soon Captain Adam and
his men barge into the base but miles
busting out those badass sword shops
again brings down some of the men and
takes Adam hostage he then ties him up
in a room and starts thinking of a way
out surprisingly Adam recognizes miles
leaving everyone in the room shocked
Charlie asks how they could know each
other and in a shocking turn of events
Adam reveals that Miles was the former
right-hand man of General Monroe in fact
he is the one who trained the entire
militia and that is why they are so
deadly but despite the Revelation miles
is focused on getting them out he
proposes a deal in which he will
surrender himself to the Monroe militia
and in exchange his group will be left
unharmed for some reason Adam accepts
probably because he's lying and soon
miles is taken away a flashback then
shows that two weeks After the Blackout
miles left for Chicago in search of his
brother and his best friend Monroe also
followed him along the way they came
across two men severely beating up a man
being the nice guy that he is Miles
approaches them takes out his gun and
shoots them dead after this the two
friends helped the victim up who is
revealed to be none other than Captain
Adam this is why he respects miles
despite their current indifferences back
in the present as the militia is
escorting miles to their base they come
across a bridge suddenly an explosion
occurs and while everyone is startled
Nora and Charlie arrive and rescue miles
before leaving they set off another
explosion to ensure that they will not
be pursued elsewhere Maggie and Aaron
who are on a mission to find Grace
finally reach her house but find it
abandoned Aaron who is revealed to be a
former Google employee knows a great
deal about computers so when he heads to
the basement he notices Grace's computer
and immediately finds out that it was
recently built indicating that the place
had electricity however when he analyzes
the machine for hours he gets no clues
tired Aaron goes upstairs and shares his
disappointment with Maggie just then his
pendant starts glowing and some nearby
headphones start blasting a song the
episode ends as Maggie's iPhone also
comes to life because of which she sees
her children after years to see what
happens next watch the second part in
series recapped